hello everyone i hope you're all having
an excellent sunday because we have
another wonderful clash between thomas
wilson barnes and
paul charles morphy and uh of course uh
welcome back to the good stuff
now it's a really wonderful game as the
title suggests it is the first one i
believe
that we're showing where morphe actually
goes for morphe's defense uh so without
further ado let's check it out as it's
it's quite a beauty this one
so barnes uh continues with his uh e4
ideas with e5 by morphe knight f3 knight
to c6
and bishop to b5 so the rui lopez is on
the board
uh and finally we have a6 by morphy uh
morphy goes for morphe's defense
and okay bishop to a4 barnes retreats
with the bishop we have knight f6
and now knight to c3 and as morphe is a
big favorite of
fighting for the center of the board he
goes bishop to b4
uh develops nicely the bishop and
attacks one of the
one of the pieces that are currently
engaged in the
in the fight for the center of the board
uh currently defending the e4 pawn
so barnes says okay you want it you can
have it he goes knight
to d5 and already there are some very
nasty ideas here
uh barnes is saying uh do you maybe want
to capture the e5
d4 pawn however if you go for this uh
then barnes can just remove the defender
of the bishop and the morphe will lose a
piece here after captures and captures
uh morphy is it will be down a piece so
morphy says okay let's go b5 first
not allow bishop captures on c6 bishop
to b3 and now still not going for
material
uh morphe big fan of development
continues with the d6 he wants to get
the bishop into the game castle
and so on uh so here after d6 we have
castles by barnes uh and it is as a move
eight that this position has
never been reached again so let's see
what happened
bishop to g4 by morphy he just nicely
continues development and now a c3
barnes prepares the strike in the center
with the d4
with bishop back to a5 by morphe and now
d4 so grabbing the center morphe's king
is still in the center of the center of
the board
so it does make sense to open up the
center uh we have e captures on d4 by
morphe
and now barnes uh removes uh the
defender of
the d5 square which is the f6 knight uh
you could also develop with bishop the
g5 you could recapture first but barnes
know what he's doing he goes for knight
captures on f6 with
check queen captures and now bishop to
d5 and now it's very unpleasant for
morphe how does he defend the knight
here
uh well uh he he could defend it with
something like king d7 he
could go bishop to d7 there are options
here however uh
morphy just uh defends by not defending
at all he goes and knights the e5 and he
goes for the attack now there's there's
a triple attack on the knight here
and he gives up a full rook on a8 so
what uh what uh what can barnes do here
uh well uh one one way is to just
capture the rook which is what barnes
did
you know uh barnes is an attacker but in
these crucial moments we've seen in
every game
where he can grab a rook he always grabs
the rook uh there there is the option of
going bishop to g5 which is
just an all-out capture fest now with
bishop to g5 we go into queen captures
uh you give up the queen temporarily
knight captures
bishop captures you get bishop captures
uh now bishop to e2 going after the rook
we get captures here but now captures
end only after captures uh does the
bishop retreat and we get this
position where uh black has two bishops
white has a bishop in the night both
players have a rook and
well there's this tension in the center
but all in all a pretty equal-ish game
black should be somewhat better due to
the bishop pair
so that is a one option for barnes
however barnes goes for the
rook right away he goes bishop captures
an a8 and now
morphy is uh well free to attack at will
which he does
he goes knight captures an f3 with check
g captures and bishop capture so now the
queen is under attack but also there's
the threat of queen g6 mate
as the bishop covers these two squares
so it would be well of course okay you
give up the dark square bishop then
queen captures that's mate
so uh barnes defends this with queen to
d2 now queen g6 will be met with queen
to g5 and if
barnes can get this in uh then uh he
should be
just winning because uh well he did just
grab a full rook there
and uh this is what he's going for
however morphy goes for d
captures on c3 now of course you cannot
capture because of bishop captures
there's the queen
and the rook so queen the g5 but now
with
this queen to g5 move morphe is actually
completely winning
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to figure out
why morphe is completely winning while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting the
double attack and for those who just
want to enjoy the show it's c captures
on b2
point being that now if bishop captures
queen captures on g5 is checkmate and if
you don't capture well there's not much
you can do the rook will fall
or the bishop doesn't really matter
sorry about that
and uh well barnes just decided to bring
back the bishop for the moment
get the king on a nice dark square so he
can trade the queen with
check and while morphy can go king to f8
uh it will still result in opening of
the g file morphe says uh
it doesn't really matter i'm just gonna
go king to e7 uh but here with king to
e7 you kind of allow barnes to
like make it a little bit interesting
because if he goes rook to b1
then okay morphe can grab the bishop
here and only now after queen captures
with check and g captures rook captures
uh
on c1 at least you don't have rook to g8
checkmate
because you freed the f1 square for your
king however
barnes again goes for queen captures on
f6 with check right away morphy plays g
captures and now
morphy is threatening this he's
threatening this and he's threatening
just rook j
checkmate the bishop still covers these
two squares okay after of course the
the bishop blocks so bishop to f4
baron barnes now has to give up the rook
on a1 so he can defend
checkmate with bishop to g3 so morphe
goes rook to g8 to check we have bishop
to g3
defending against checkmate and only now
b captures an a1
grabbing a queen so rook captures an a1
now okay the f1 square has been vacated
for the king
but now f5 taking advantage of that this
capture is impossible due to
captures and now barnes has to decide
what to do
and there isn't all that much f4 is
coming and you will not be able to move
the bishop so there really isn't much
you can do here
king f1 is one option uh but barnes
first decides for a4 he won't he says
okay i'm going to give up the bishop but
at least i may
i might create a pass pawn here and i do
have the a8 square defended
with my bishop so morph while morphy
could go f4 right away he first goes
bishop to b6 he has a very very nasty
idea here
so uh barnes goes a characters on b4 on
b5 and now uh
morphy just goes f4 he will he traps the
bishop here
barnes creates a pass pawn here now of
course a7 a8 is coming but morphe now
plays
f captures on g3 barnes recaptures
but now there's the problem of this pin
so rook captures on g3 with
check the f pawn cannot capture we have
kinked the h2
and now while you could go rook to g2
with chuck morphy finds a
a very cool idea rook to g6
and now he says okay barnes you go ahead
and put this a7 pawn
however it doesn't really do all that
much because if you push a7
uh here with morphe prepare this bishop
captures on f2 now with the these four
squares covered
it doesn't matter if barnes gets the
queen into the game rook h6 is checkmate
as there is a wall here the white king
simply cannot cross
so barnes saw this he said all right
we're not giving up the f2 pawn he
played
rook to f1 defending it but now morphy
can do the exact same thing
only a little bit differently so for the
last time feel free to pause the video
and
win this game for morphe it's a mating 4
for black so
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
using the exact same idea only two
squares
upwards and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's bishop to d4
uh what morphe is planning now is going
bishop e5 followed by bishop to f4 and
then it's the same
we had the idea where the bishop was
here now morphy wants the same wall
with the bishop here so barnes tries to
escape
he plays king to h3 but there is nothing
better
bishop to e5 by morphe the bishop is
coming to f4 and this is unstoppable
uh we have king to h4 and now comes the
bishop to f4 the wall has been created
and there is nothing much to be done
so here barnes could have resigned but
barnes the gentleman that he is he just
played a7
and he allowed mate to appear on the
board which morphe did he played rook to
h6 and this was checkmate
so on move 30 we have checkmate and uh
what a wonderful victory for paul
charles morphy
so again we have a really crazy game
where barnes really gives it
gives it his best and then in the
crucial moment where he needs to step
up he just grabs the rook instead of
going for that capture fest we've shown
uh so it it's uh weird barnes has this
huge potential i
i think barnes had the potential to be
like the greatest player of that
era if he like uh uh if he like
maybe maybe uh had an opponent like
morphy to look up to
uh but with morphy gone i'm pretty sure
barnes could just you know
hold his own against anyone and i don't
think barnes was
all that i mean he was a chess player of
course but i don't think it was like the
main thing he was interested in life
uh it was just you know something that
uh
preoccupied him but he he definitely was
a huge talent uh
but but if you're wondering why barnes
started marching with the king why not
leave the king there
it doesn't really help him because after
this bishop to d4 you can
just like if you play something else
it's still just mate on the spot it's uh
like you can go rook to h6 check right
away
but you can also just give check king h3
and now rook to h6's check it doesn't
really matter
or even if somehow the king winds up on
g1
then rook to h1 will again deliver
checkmate so
not much for barnes to do there but it's
a very gentlemanly of him to play it out
all the way until the end
so that's uh the game i do hope you
enjoyed it and that it at least
slightly improved your your sunday uh i
would like to thank
david marcus matthew stroud jason barr
dennis jalet and
ben o'neill and ryan doyle for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
i just realized i haven't uh updated my
interface
from the previous video i mean i did
update it i just didn't click update
so now we get we get the same people
twice
but you know uh it's uh you know lucky
you
what can i say uh so the the interface
will be updated in in the next one
uh so yeah uh that's it uh thank you for
watching and uh i
i will see you guys soon uh with some
more videos from the paul morphy saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever happens uh in
the chess world
the legends of chess tournament starts
tomorrow so thank you
i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your sunday